foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week okay we got a lot of boneheads
this week but every week we have a lot
of bonuses well you know with these maga
maga Republicans there's no need to uh
think that we're gonna have a low
inventory of [ __ ] morons
um but this week one really worked its
way out front he really and I mean so
much so that they even had like a kind
of a small parade for him oh um to a
courtroom it was pretty cool I don't
want to give it away but yeah yeah but
um but this week our boneheads
um again we had three of them Senator
Marco Rubio which again he's always a
bonehead always and then we have mayman
oz Dr Oz is a [ __ ] idiot of course
he's a moment and then
scabby Steve Bannon who has been Eve
Bannon charged with six
six
crimes in the state of New York
including money laundering and deep
fraud scheming to defraud
um is is part of those six counts and he
was he was shown yesterday to be
surrendering to the prosecutors and the
best part is normally when someone
surrenders like that you know like they
don't per block them no normally but
they were like no we're gonna burp walk
your ass dummy and they did the burp
walk and it was I mean everyone's
waiting like it was a premiere of a
Hollywood film we've got the Velvet row
people chanting and sharing obviously
because they hate them but the crowd
there you know inside and outside of the
building uh they were dedicated fans
dedicated fans that hate his [ __ ]
guts oh this this that lady outside like
I said she deserves flowers yeah yeah no
she is the modern day Saint oh she is
beautiful beautiful and I think I found
her on Twitter so I'm gonna try to see
if we can
get her to uh come here so we can thank
her I'd like to thank her personally is
what I'd like to do for her I'd also
like to know democracy you know which uh
which kind of arraignments or events
she's going to next
uh just to give her some moral support
yeah well I mean I know I know
um it sounds like she does events all
the time she's constantly fighting for
our democracy which is good because we
need people like her in the fight
especially people who are who are spicy
and Saucy because um we need to we need
to really Hammer these son of a [ __ ]
as we see with these boneheads this week
yeah why did Senator Marco Rubio make it
on our list
that is a what was the clip that I sent
you this year you have no idea you know
what I'm trying to remember you said
some dumb [ __ ] this week so what was it
I don't know there was something because
this was I feel like this was an early
week it is early it was earlier on in
the week it is where uh he talked about
um storage oh storage yeah yeah when he
was on Fox and Friends yeah so yeah yeah
so that was the uh that was him do you
have the Clipper do you needed he's also
well he's also uh I'm pulling up Clips
here but he's also um if you want to
find that storage clip he's all he was
also very
upset about the leaks so if you'll find
the storage clip I'll play the clip here
of the uh the leaks here because he was
on Fox and Friends and he thinks it's
egregious yeah you know forget the
crimes forget the crimes committed well
they don't care about that when you
steal top secret documents what he's
upset about is people are leaking that
these that this former president
committed crimes it's ridiculous that
you would leak that he committed crime
how dare they how dare they that's how
we should be outraged about how dare
they inform the public about the extent
you know not the details specifically
but how dare all right these these law
enforcement agencies say like hey press
you might want to know that Donald Trump
had these nuclear documents at his kind
of disposal in his private Residence at
Mar-A-Lago not under lock and key in
some uh facility that was supposed like
a skiff or somewhere it's supposed to be
or you know protected by the government
it was just in a desk
crazy
let's listen let's listen a little Marco
here try to justify how the leaks are
worse than the crimes committed no you
can understand why uh you know when we
first heard about this stuff we heard
well maybe it's things like a note from
Kim Jong-un to uh president Trump that
he wanted juicy trying really hard here
by the way yeah
through this Washington Post report
highly classified documents at
Mar-A-Lago uh that only a cabinet level
officer or hire could even look at that
doesn't seem like the kind of thing you
should have uh in your post-presidential
desk drawer
Steve newsey really try I mean he's
trying so hard he's like I don't I don't
wanna I don't want to be a total [ __ ]
too right now but I'm just gonna ask you
the question that I think is a rational
you know reasonable question that most
people wonder which is why did he have
these documents that are only available
to be seen and viewed and held by people
of cabinet level status or other people
like them that have been given access
right like why do they have them I mean
this restaurant Brian kill meat over
here is like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh God do
you see enough of the half-assed
journalism enough of the half-ass
because this is not what week two or so
that that Ducey has now been asking just
he's not even complicated questions he's
just like why did he have these
documents and it seems like he has been
disproved like you know
he's asked Marco Rubio and I mean so
he's not he's not out of line here he
really he's not doing his job it's the
bare minimum it's the bare minimum
and to be like yeah he's just edging up
to bare minimum he's like look I mean
why did he have the stuff their minimum
should be why are you still supporting a
person who is alleged to have top stole
to our government stop top secret
documents and stored them in a place
where anyone could get to them and
you're on the Senate intelligence
committee tell US senator you being on
that how are you still supporting this
person that should be the [ __ ]
question but but let's see what Marco's
answer is here about the crimes that are
committed let's listen
well let's break this down first of all
again we really don't know because let's
go back no we do know yeah okay
the summation is coming from one side in
one place yep yep it sure is it sure is
because they had to go take the top
secret documents that he stole that's
why it's coming from one place called
the uh Department of what the hell is
that department called Justice yeah
Justice is that how you say it okay
that's that's how the the Europeans say
it oh okay department of justice justice
and as sources with knowledge of the
investigation well who are the sources
with knowledge of the investigation the
people who are investigating yes
not only that
um who are the sources Donald Trump is
the [ __ ] Source he's the reason why
we know that doj says hey look we've got
this stuff we don't want to release it
can you just comply and he goes no no no
no I'm not going to comply and then it
was just back and forth 20-month thing
and then now Donald Trump you know from
August 8th from the from the [ __ ]
get-go he goes
this is this is an obstruction of my own
uh my own Liberties and freedom and
privacy like they're they're they're
coming they're coming into my home and
and the rating and they're going through
melania's stuff and they're going
through my my son uh uh Baron you know
all of this stuff where it's like
if you had just done
what you're supposed to do which is
don't steal the documents right don't
then you wouldn't have had the FBI come
into your home and then if you didn't
lie and steal and hide them over a
20-month period they wouldn't have had
to come with a search warrant yeah they
wouldn't be investigating for
obstruction right but Marco Rubio thinks
that it's not about obstruction it's a
storage issue let's listen this is
really at its core a storage argument
that they're making right they're
arguing there are documents there they
don't deny that he should have access to
those documents but they deny is that
they were not properly stored that's not
at all what they're saying not even
close even the Department of Justice in
their appeal this morning is saying look
these aren't his documents it's not his
[ __ ] it's our [ __ ] it's the government
[ __ ] they're not his he is not so
documents that he could have any no he
is not supposed to have these documents
right that at the heart of it is the
actual issue here is that he stole our
[ __ ] and and let's remember that when
you're the president you are a servant
of the people you serve the people in
the office United States exactly and
then when you leave that office another
person comes in and they serve the
people and when you leave you don't
serve the people you do you know you
would hope that you would try to do some
good but Donald Trump is [ __ ] just
blowing this [ __ ] to pieces and burning
it down the guy left with documents
denied he had the documents was shown
that he had the documents admitted that
he had the documents then he said I
Declassified the documents meanwhile
everyone's like it doesn't work that way
you cannot declassify these a former
president cannot just retrospectively
say hey or retroactively just say you
know what I thought I thought about it
yeah I thought I considered it I thought
when I was present so it is I'm gonna
post it on true social and now it is the
law of the land it's really stupid and
Marco Rubio's really [ __ ] stupid and
let me tell you if you think Marco Rubio
is a bonehead and you live in Florida
there's something you can do about even
if you don't live in Florida there's
something you can do about a battle
demings man she is coming up in this
race she's gonna kick his ass in Florida
I think she may help pull uh Charlie
Chris and Charlie Chris may help pull
her over the line in Florida have some
[ __ ] Common Sense brought back to
Florida instead of this fascist State
blueprint that they have going on there
speaking of Elections and States Dr Oz
is trying trying his best to look like
he's from Pennsylvania
um he's been unsuccessful at every every
point
uh you know down the road well I mean
you know he he's like a fish out of
water here because not only not only
does is he not from Pennsylvania it
doesn't even appear that he's from
Pennsylvania and really honestly
um he's lying his ass off this morning
on Fox news now I don't know exactly why
he's on our bonad but he was on Fox news
this morning here's a clip from him
talking about how just lying to
Pennsylvania we put him on we put him on
this week's bonehead for the physical
comment the physical yeah yeah that was
the that was the like oh the 15 minutes
uh for a physical oh yeah yeah get that
clip for me because that's an old that's
an old clip from a while back but this
is a brand new fresh clip brought to you
by the Tony Michaels podcast this one's
fresh right off the presses from from
New Jersey straight to Pennsylvania yeah
let's listen as the brace tightens
dramatically which it is doing no no
it's not no it's not it's not tightening
no that's not true you're a [ __ ]
idiot it's not tightening it's getting
closer to election time if that's what
you mean but it's not tightening people
begin to understand how radical he
really is
okay that the guy wears a hoodie all
right all right also the guy the guy is
he's like what six eight all right some
[ __ ] like that which if I was that tall
and I was that big
I would probably have a hard time
finding a suit you know especially in
that quantity to be like look I'll wear
the suit when you guys elect me yeah but
do you think people in Pennsylvania that
are gonna lose are you gonna think are
you gonna convince them that wearing a
hoodie a Carhartt hoodie is radical are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you're talking about
dog one of the heartbeat of [ __ ] USA
right
this is ridiculous
that the Rust Belt that think that these
people are going to accuse John
fetterman of being a radical because he
wears a hoodie like God forbid you wear
the brand for the clothing that we wear
and our uniforms right on our Blue
Collar jobs [ __ ] you man how dare you
you know you radical listen this is it
gets better the independent vote is
Shifting in my direction no it's not
this election
she's even like hmm I don't believe you
yeah I don't I don't know what to say
here um when you're talking about that
is not the truth let's listen confidence
that we will prevail in November we got
the right ideas at the right time and
he's unable to articulate a defense for
what he likes to do which is a tweet out
ideas that sound good to him at the time
but make no sense and hurt the
Commonwealth of Pennsylvania and isn't
this the guy who tweeted the video about
him going to a grocery store and getting
crew today yeah yeah I'm not the same
guy yeah I I think it's the same guy but
maybe I'm wrong maybe maybe that's not
the thing what I will say is Dr Oz is
clearly butt hurt because every time
that Oz does something fetterman and his
team post something that ends up going
viral and it's pretty funny right when
he talked about being from South Florida
they released a video of just like
zooming in on Google Maps and then going
below South Florida like oh look this is
where he's from New Jersey so you mean
South South Philly yeah South Philly
yeah yeah yeah uh you said South Florida
oh did I say oh you said South Florida
I'm mixing them people in Pennsylvania
are now going to be anti-game shoes
you're a radical game this is what
happens when I get little sleep and
we're talking about Republican boneheads
you know I know well I apologize I meant
New Jersey what happened what's
happening is you're confusing
Republicans in Florida for republicans
in Pennsylvania because they they I mean
they share the same fascist ideology
right well here is uh Dr Oz now I'm not
sure when this was what year
um this is some sort of speech that he's
giving to the National Governors
Association and I'm not sure why he's
demeaning people who don't have health
insurance but he's doing it let's listen
now when you go home today what should
you do I think you ought to think about
15-minute physicals your local hospitals
will fund these they're incredibly
inexpensive to run you can screen
thousands of people for almost nothing
and you allow a conversation and take
place and more of a festival-like
setting it's not scary and I mentioned
earlier that almost everybody who comes
to our our 50-minute physicals has a job
but a lot don't have insurance give them
a way of crawling back out of the abyss
of darkness of fear over not having the
help they need and give them an
opportunity because they don't have the
right to health but they have the right
to access a chance to get that health
so is he saying in this group because I
ain't take that what he's saying is is
that people who don't have insurance
don't have a right to health so what is
what he said he literally they don't
have a right to health but they do have
a right to access
it's very strange it's very strange his
take on don't also like a festival-like
setting you're just gonna go like okay
for anyone who has done a physical there
are a lot of things that go in right
you're getting your weight your
temperature taken they're inspecting
other parts of your body it doesn't seem
that's really like a 15 minute thing to
do like a festive thing and not only
that but like he what he's proposing is
like he's setting up a bunch of goddamn
tents in a in a parking lot like it's
like it's some sort of festival-like
setting oh that's what it means like
people are gonna like come there and
yeah they just walk in walk out but what
he's at the festival though Gabe you you
go to all these like these little these
little trailers and these little tents
where they have really shitty food like
it's great they play [ __ ] taste
awesome it's all [ __ ] fried it's all
greasy I mean you can't even I mean by
the time you get done eating it the
napkin is just soaked and natural but
it's they're it's fantastic funnel cake
corn dogs lemonade not turkey legs I
keep going what else you got right I
mean cotton candy I mean you name it
caramel corn yeah a kettle corn I mean
you just keep going uh all great stuff
by the way all festive stuff but is that
what he's saying is we're supposed to
the way that I take this right now is
that he's talking about setting up tents
in some open area like some field or
some parking lot if he's talking about
being near a hospital right in terms of
proximity to a hospital and what they
have available in resources but the idea
of what he's talking about reminds me of
of like a fire Festival right like it
would be the fire Festival of physicals
is the way that I take it him describing
do you know what the fire Festival is
I've never been but I I've oh no there's
no way that you could only well there's
only happened once it was a bit it was a
one and done it was a failure I could I
could have went there oh you you hadn't
you had all those no I didn't know I did
not but but there it is a possibility
that I could have sure yeah you could
have gone there and you could have
gotten uh sandwich with uh a tomato
lettuce on on uh on bread on one talking
about the one you're talking about the
one that the Ja Rule one yeah the Ja
Rule and the other guy that's right is
it McFarland is it no it's uh um I know
who you're talking about yeah yeah
there's a Netflix down here yeah Billy
McFarland yeah yeah I could have went I
mean I didn't go yeah I wouldn't go to
anything like that but that's what that
but the way that he describes in a
festival-like setting that could be it
which is it sounds like an absolute [ __ ]
show based on you know what is involved
with the physical and how many people
are available not only that the biggest
thing when it comes to a physical is
your goddamn privacy to be in a room
with a closed door so no one else can
see what you're doing it's a very
vulnerable thing to do because you take
off your clothes oh hey let me check
this let me check that I'm in a you know
whatever the doctor's gonna check you in
certain places to make sure you're
healthy everywhere right the idea that
you go in and out with the hospital gown
naked and a tent or even without a gown
like he's like oh it's very inexpensive
inexpensive it's because they have porta
potties at this uh 15 minute physical
special thing at this Festival I don't
know who knows like like a whole Bank of
them you know what I'm talking about
yeah no you know when you when you eat
the funnel cake and you eat the
breakfast sometimes you gotta through
right well you got the beer tent and the
beer garden and everything else I mean
sometimes you got it you gotta go you
got it sounds it sounds like an absolute
[ __ ] show I would say it's the fire
Festival
of physicals
well Dr Oz is definitely a [ __ ]
bone-in this week so thanks Dr Oz for
making the cut here
um let's go to our DM speaking of [ __ ]
shows uh Peter Navarro your buddy Peter
the honorable mention this week oh my
God this [ __ ] guy I cannot believe
this Peter Navarro
I guess he filled in for for Banning
yesterday because Bannon was um I don't
know what was wrong was he sick what
what happened why couldn't Steve I think
it was I think he was a little bit busy
he was traveling Oh okay he was on the
road walking yeah he was walking uh busy
walking couldn't couldn't couldn't be on
the air but I'm glad that Peter Navarro
was so nice so you're saying you can't
podcast when you're handcuffed is that
what you're saying no you can't podcast
from jail either so I am super excited
that Donald Trump and all the other mag
Republicans are going to lose their
megaphone that is Steve Bannon well you
know Peter Navarro talks about that in
this clip that's why he is he's next on
the list by the way he is he is
definitely not going to be podcasting uh
for Steve Bannon very long yeah they're
gonna need a new guest co-host I like
the idea of them just handing off to the
next person to the next person and each
person is getting arraigned or indicted
or arrested and put in jail and they're
like they just have a a long list of
people that are all frauds right
Margaret David Green's gonna be a a Coho
a guest coach that's going to be
arraigned I mean this is all going to
happen you know the real crime here is
where in the [ __ ] is he placing himself
on this green screen why would you
choose this picture why is this is this
not the CDC I have no idea what is this
I'm not certain but I feel like it's
really [ __ ] weird why wouldn't I mean
if you were gonna go anywhere you wanted
to go you'd think you'd go somewhere
other than this business park or
whatever the hell this is yeah what the
[ __ ] let's listen let's listen to uh
bonehead Navarro here about it I'm here
today talking with you
yeah because Stephen K Bannon is yeah
powerful political voice right now in
America no no was he was he was he's not
he he's arrested he's gonna go to jail
he was you can't you can't you podcast
from jail but you know let's let's
finish
and they want to shut him up yep that's
what this is all about yeah it's about
he committed crimes and he's gonna go to
jail for those crimes even even if the
the former guy
um
the former guy pardoned him from federal
crimes right he's not going to get away
with the state current yes
I don't know if it's a CDC I thought
because he's weird it's like it's almost
like he's like you know what um just
pick out the local business park give me
a picture well I don't it's definitely
not in DC I don't think so I mean like
look at this looks like a mountain ridge
in the background if anyone in the chat
knows this the hell this is Aunt yeah
because I've seen him use it when he's
talked about uh fauci before and I don't
know if those two are connected so if
he's like oh this is a building there's
a medical facility of some sort uh I
don't know it is really weird it's
really the high crime here
um is that the background that he's
using maybe he didn't know what he was
you know he's standing from a green
screen maybe there's two types of
backgrounds he does one is uh he's got
the well he's got a day and night
version of the what looks like uh
um
it looks like I think it's it's a DC
background I think it's a DC background
um somebody on somebody said where's the
chat the chat no he said Wuhan lab in
China oh Jesus Christ let me see it oh
man that kid please tell me that's not
he didn't Place himself in China let me
see why you're looking at it yes this is
where this is it Robert from YouTube is
correct uh you win you win the
background award boom boom right on it
God China oh see I told you I told you
there's a reason why he brings it up
when he talks about what it is okay well
let's let's listen to this clip because
this this almost gets better this almost
gets better I don't know if it can get
better but let's listen in a blue
stronghold using lawfare
to try to what what is
what is law fear I'm I'm not is he
saying is he is did he mean Warfare and
then he's like use the law I think
that's what he's saying is I don't know
I think you the [ __ ] out of someone and
tell you what I think I think Webster's
uh dictionary needs to jump in and give
a comment here right what law fair right
or maybe maybe like this Festival it's a
word it's a [ __ ] there's a word I wonder
I wonder if it's like you know like Dr
Oz talked about a festival-like setting
this one is like a law fair so you're
there at a fair and you're like hey look
this law school and that law firm and
this and that you know and this
right-wing nut job that spreading
conspiracy theories is the lawyer that
works for Donald Trump named Elena Haba
who knows who knows Tony the best part
about the other crime here is this
little thing right here it says Dr Peter
Navarro okay let's continue the silence
the man the man K Bannon
who
has through the force of his intellect
take in this show are the number one
podcast
and show in politics in the world
okay number one that is that's such an
atrocity why don't you folks do me a
favor and spread around this show the
Tony Michael's podcast and burned in the
week so we can be number one so these
[ __ ] idiots don't get to say this
kind of [ __ ] because really honestly
then maybe that's the highest crime here
with what Navarre is saying but you know
I looked up lawfare by the way yeah yeah
okay what lawfare is the use of legal
systems and institutions to damage or
delegitimize delegitimize an opponent or
to deter individuals usage of their
legal rights so he's saying love fare on
Democracy is because he's projecting
here he's like ah they're using law fair
to shut him up no he talks too much
right and he crimes too much right two
things kind of different some of them
are the same but just because you talk
too much doesn't mean they can't you
know hold you accountable for criming
too much and there's a thing they can do
Peter Navarro so if that's what you
consider long video so Peter Navarro is
our dishonorable mention this week for
bone end of the week
Gabe who end up being our Alpha cook
this week who got caught
Donald J Trump as the alpha cook two
weeks in a row yeah he was on it last
week
and he came back and he was like last
week he got Alpha cook last week oh my
God what was he Alpha I don't even
remember we got Alpha [ __ ] by the doj oh
yeah yeah now I remember he is because
he was like hey this is [ __ ] and the
doj was like man you don't want to keep
doing this we're just gonna keep
embarrassing you because you broke the
[ __ ] law and they embarrassed him
this morning again too yeah I don't know
if you they don't know if you saw this
but they embarrassed the [ __ ] out of him
um when they when they filed they filed
the doj filed a response right last
night it was yes yeah doj filed the
response and basically said he doesn't
own these documents and really honestly
the judge is getting cucked there too
yeah yeah um the judge is getting really
cut there too but but um let's see why
Donald Trump was Alpha cook this week
whoa hey there we are this is good this
is this is reception dude this is like
I am not wearing the same shirt I just
own a lot of black shirts I promise okay
all right it's I'm not pulling a Steve
Bannon I was just gonna say that sounds
like Steve Bannon one shirt and I
launder my shirts not the money that's
not the money okay okay so here is uh
the video of Rick Wilson absolutely
turning Donald Trump into a cuck and we
we went over this yesterday but let's
let's play it again I can't wait I would
imagine that Rick is gonna challenge him
here um but let's let's see what says
you Rick to just give Donald Trump a
message since you threatened to sue the
Lincoln project this morning go for it
go for it [ __ ] come at me I can't wait
we're we're delighted by the thought
that you would try to sue us Donald do
it do it I double dog dare you you know
when we put up the Billboards in Times
Square of Jared and Ivanka during the
covet crisis at the end of the 2020
campaign we received this letter from
Mark cassowitz Donald Trump's attorney
and it was this complete you know
blustering [ __ ] show oh we will
certainly sue you we read it in the Bane
voice right
you're not going to sue anybody Donald
you're not going to do [ __ ] you're not
going to do a goddamn thing you are weak
you were impotent you were flabby you
were sitting there in the bridal suite
at Mar-A-Lago or in the bridal suite at
Bedminster grinding your gears wondering
why oh [ __ ] the Lincoln project no
matter how many times you've tried to
kill us keeps coming at you you know oh
my God I I it just it um what sweet
words from from Rick Wilson the funniest
they're uh
a couple funny moments there but I think
my favorite is I double dog dare you
which I don't hear very often these days
right uh was a very popular thing to say
as a kid right and I you know I probably
could say it even now but when you're
when you're challenging someone as an
adult nobody says I double dog dare you
and it just adds to the whole like the
hilarious nature of this whole thing
which is Donald Trump thinks he can sue
whoever he wants because they made
something again practicing the freedom
of speech the First Amendment
and what they're saying is not untrue it
is completely 100 true he grifted people
from their money took it and then took
advantage of a group and hopefully now
that they're exposing Donald Trump for
the fraud and the criminal that he is
maybe they will turn around and say [ __ ]
we should not be supporting this guy
because what you're talking about is the
Lincoln project edit we don't have time
to play the ad here but we did post this
full re uh uh react to not just not just
the ad and Rick Wilson's video but we
actually we showed the Donald Trump um
fraud social post over on our YouTube
channel so so go subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast subscribe right now and
you can go to uh our Channel and see
that portion of the show yesterday from
how we reacted to not only the video of
Rick Wilson but also the the true social
post and the ad that Lincoln project
that's so pissed Donald Trump off and
really really gotten his snowflake like
feelings and and caused Rick to make
this video but this also this type of uh
response is I believe there's a changing
um
uh kind of
attitude for people on the left or even
people in the center or on the right
that are done with Donald Trump and the
mag Republicans but what I feel like is
happening is people are are fed up right
but they're also seeing the way in which
uh Democrats respond which is
hey Everyone's entitled to be an idiot
uh they don't you know they don't ever
have uh or they've never suffered from
good manners right they there's this
constant calling out now of Maga are a
bunch of fascists their policies are
terrible and detrimental to your
livelihood and well-being they don't
have your uh well-being you know into
consideration it's only for themselves
and and how they can profit
and so now you're seeing people like
[ __ ] this man [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
everything that you're doing right now
because you are a terrible human and you
don't represent me or anyone else that
is supposed to be your constituents and
I say I think now there's a changing
behavior and an attitude where people
are just like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
call you [ __ ] out for the monster
that you are and everyone's like yeah
this is great we should do more of this
speaking of calling out monsters
brings us to the Bone end of the week
Steve Bannon our winner because
as you know there is a great video of a
sweet sweet lady and again I'm I want to
send her flowers so if I can figure out
where to send them to I'm going to send
her some flowers here because she did
this country a great service yesterday
when she was standing there as Steve
Bannon entered the the courthouse to
surrender himself the prosecutors for
the six crimes they charged him with the
best part is is he tried to play victim
but she wasn't having any of it let's
let's watch let's watch this beautiful
beautiful it's like a Hollywood Premiere
look at this it is it is it's great
[Music]
this is irony on the very day the mayor
of this city has a delegation Down On
the Border they're persecuting people
I don't know if you caught this game but
there's a lady who is being very loud in
the background and as debating starts to
speak she's like uh-uh [ __ ] and
she gets closer and closer and closer to
drown him out and the end the ending on
this on this clip is just people need to
bring whistles you know because this
reminds me this reminds me of when Steve
Bannon tried to spread some [ __ ]
after one of his court appearances and
there's the guy in DC and there was the
guy with the whistle which I think might
have been the same guy that blew the
whistle at margin Taylor green and Matt
Gates last year and made them run away
and back down after they said we will
not back down boom blow the whistle
crazy Powers this whistle has against
fascists it's amazing well you know what
he got there he used to have a guitar
and he and on the guitar it said this
machine kills fascists and maybe a
whistle with this machine kills fascists
on it maybe maybe we should put that
somewhere I don't know I'm just saying
but let's let's watch how she
she kills fascist here and fascism as
he's trying to spew it out his pie hole
take a step back
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you greasy two-bit grifter oh she is
after my heart Gabe she's actually I
have this image in my mind of people
that are in the rotating door and
they're catching like moments of it
they're like Oh you mean like so they
can't hear all of this right so they
might you know they might catch like
something that's faint or whatever but
as they're going through like parts are
be like you two you're like you crazy
you get grifter like you know it's like
oh my god well what a great piece of
video but Gabe there was a piece of
footage of Steve Bannon the bone end of
the week
that was even better I didn't know it
could get even better because yesterday
we watched that piece of footage on the
show but this other piece of footage
hadn't happened yet and I was like I
don't think this day can get any better
but it totally did it got so much better
with this little piece of footage
and it is it is Steve Bannon and it
appears that he's being per blocked
let's take a look
there's a very good chance that they'll
shut him up or kill him at Rikers they
oh well yeah they're not gonna put up
with this [ __ ] I have I have an idea
that uh if he were to say [ __ ] because I
don't actually think he would when he
goes through and they're like all right
cool we got to do a cavity check which I
feel I have an immense amount of just uh
predicting the immense amount of like
sympathy uh for whoever has to do that
check right like uh that those are
cavities you do not want to search that
is that is like uh that's like when you
you find like a beached like shark and
you're like hey what the hell did this
thing eat and then it's like a license
plastic you know this [ __ ] that's what
it's gonna be there's no telling how
many things that Steve Bannon has
keistered and forgotten about there's no
telling how many wearing what three or
four shirts and a jacket like we don't
know what's underneath those other black
shirts well you don't you have no idea
you have no idea and he is a greasy
grifter I want to point out though and
this is a great shot of this though this
is going to be the iconic shot right
here on the screen of Steve Bannon oh
yeah in a pair of handcuffs here as
these as these Marshals are taking him
into the courtroom and but I want to
point out something
they did all this on purpose oh yeah you
got the barricade there they got the
[ __ ] media barricade they're like no
we're gonna walk him right down this
hallway everyone's set up we're gonna do
the burp Walk we're gonna let America
see this guy loses [ __ ] mind and
we're gonna create a piece of content
that's gonna live in history forever and
ever and ever and I just my heart hopes
my heart hopes Gabe that there is a
moment when
Donald Trump is finally held accountable
that they do the exact same thing to him
that they did yeah yeah
I can't wait I mean like this right here
right now because right now what's
happening uh they have the Venice Film
Festival that that I think might still
be happening or just ended
I'm getting the same Vibes as this the
only difference is they don't have a red
carpet and a backdrop right but they've
got a barricade to be like no no press
and reporters you're on this side and
the people who are premiering in this
film are on this side and bannon's film
is just called uh fraud [ __ ] I don't
know what it's called treason Hunters
yeah yeah treason Hunters
um you know it really
again it warms my heart that uh Steve
Bannon is being toted off to jail and
you know here's the thing he's being
held accountable for crimes that we know
he committed and the reason why we know
it is because Donald Trump pardoned him
for these crimes federally so in essence
he had to admit right to these crimes
but we don't know what the crimes were
right because they were just like look
well they might have heard them of the
charges
of the indictment that they charged him
with right right and if I think it was
an exchange of him doing what he does
every day which is to try to overturn
this country to give it back to Trump
well the reason I mean Steve Bannon left
the White House and left the
administration as the advisor after I
think it was after Charleston right
it could be yeah I think because it was
that point when Steve Bannon said ah
okay my young Padawan has learned
because he was like oh they were good
people on both sides you know uh
misunderstanding it's like oh you're
defending these these Nazis you're
defending the people that came through
the town and we're like ah or
Charlottesville sorry I said Charleston
uh
but I think at that point was I think it
was shortly after Steve Bannon was like
okay the young boy has grown out to be a
man a racist man
well speaking of padawans and Steve
Bannon here's one other good clip now
this is from real America's voices the
same Trader who's network and one of our
favorites one of our favorite years uh
boneheads Charlie Kirk whining and
crying about Steve Bannon listen to this
is beautiful there's another piece of
beautiful footage so now the priority is
indicted he's so upset oh my God he's so
upset Gabe like I haven't even started
this clip and I'm I'm gonna tears are
coming to Minds because he's so upset
he's Steve Bannon
it's a term we've used quite often here
on this program anarcho tyranny
Anarchy on the streets tyranny against
the political dissidents
tyranny in the sheets is that what is
that where he's getting this from that's
exactly what I thought he was gonna say
when he started when he's uh
something in the streets and I think
something in this house in the sheets
right
right we should make it we should make a
shirt says Anarchy in the streets
tyranny in the sheets put it Mark it
down mark it down we're gonna make a
t-shirt everyone you heard that we're
gonna we're gonna do a t-shirt design of
Anarchy and tyranny in the sheets so
let's listen
they will use political force and power
to lock up conservatives but thugs
criminals child Predators pedophiles
arsonists murderers
no bail
but if you dare speak out in favor of
Donald Trump we will raid your home
no no that's not how that works
that's hilarious wish silly little freak
which is which is funny because I almost
use an exact same line in this new
upcoming what was that which is oh I say
if you go against or you speak out
against Trump in the mega yeah uh
fascists then you are an Enemy of the
State because that's the same that's the
same language that Trump was using
during the Pennsylvania rally where he
was like ah you're an enemy in this
state you know obviously you know saying
in a joking manner but then saying in a
serious way Joe Biden is in is the Enemy
of the State which is like also are we
gonna ignore that the guy's being
investigated for Espionage like he's he
violated the Espionage Act nothing
screams Enemy of the State more than
[ __ ] treason well I mean they are
treasonous pieces of [ __ ] and uh let's
give our bone end of the week or
treasonous piece of [ __ ] of the week his
dude Steve Bannon you won bone net of
the week thanks buddy for being on the
bone of the week let's give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of the week boom boom Oh my God SB Steve
Bannon SB scabby bonehead scabby
bonehead Steve Bannon thanks for coming
to this segment of bone end of the week
and I make sure every single Friday you
join us on the Tony Michaels podcast in
the mind is touch Network for bone end
of the week subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast do not forget because
we do a show every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and we simulcast to the minus touch
Facebook page also don't forget to
subscribe here if you're watching on the
Midas touch Network subscribe here now
because you're probably watching on on
replay on Friday nights because we do
that every single week now also follow
us at Tony Michaels pod so you can vote
on bone end of the week on the pole
because you vote you decide we break it
down every single Friday in the second
hour the Tony Michaels podcast and don't
forget to download every single episode
on Apple's Spotify and Google
hey it was a great week for boneheads we
had some great contestants I mean
they're you know democracy and Justice
really coming through in the 11th hour
here I know you know I'm wondering
what's going on the manga Ultra bonehead
King he came out front it was close I
mean when it was started there was a
moment where you sent me a screenshot
and you're like oh boy
oh is this possible he is a [ __ ]
bonehead though but Bannon
he really pulled it out like I knew he
would I knew I knew he would be our
bonehead of the week thank you everyone
for joining us stick around if you're on
the Tony Michaels podcast we have a few
announcements right after the song stick
around thanks for joining us bone end of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]